pour pauline à romorantin
l'ambiance est au calme et au charme
doux du patrimoine solognot magnifique
et habiter dans tous les sens du terme
les murs du grand hôtel du lion-d'or
transpire l'histoire avec un grand h
celle de la sologne éternelle c'est une
hôtel depuis 1774 hôtels et restaurants
auberges et en fait c'est une demeure
qui a appartenu à proche de françois 1er
donc à cette partie renaissance en fait
ils sont effet voilà c'est ça avec les
fenêtres à meneaux depuis si un bâtiment
qui est plus à la fois contemporain dans
sa construction mais qui reprend aussi
toute une période avec napoléon iii
et puis là je vais vous entraîner la
cuisine et du sort du brochet il disait
quoi françois 1er déjà ah oui car telle
est notre bon plaisir
on va pouvoir s'attaquer à la dette
au programme un ourlet de brochets façon
lion d'or pour pauline le challenge et
couches taureau par la première
opération ça va être de lever enfiler
bon eh ben on va faire ça c'est pas
gagné pauline il va falloir remonter le
courant plus sûrement qu'un saumon
sauvage et on décolle voilà il faut
décoller la chaire de l'art est fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ensuite chef cash
mais le parler un petit peu
alors le pari ça veut dire ça veut dire
retirer les partis qui sont un petit peu
moins esthétique et dans un souci anti
gaspi ces déchets vont être réutilisés
tout est ok pour le brochet c'est par
une farce
on va rajouter des eu d'accord de la
crème et un assaisonnement
une fois la mousse préparer en farsi
enrouler le brochet sur lui-même et on
enfourne à 180 degrés
on va mettre à peu près 25 minutes on va
la laisser cuire tranquillement et on
assaisonne avec quoi un petit beurre
blanc au vinaigre de sureau local s'il
vous plaît aux 500 euros c'est un
vinaigre pratiquement au bout alors ça
embarquant réduction c'est ça aussi
c'est que la réduction ensuite eu leur
ajouter la crème et après réduire en
temps une finition avec le nombre sa
part et gourmand vraiment très gourmand
et ça fait vraiment très très bon pour
maintenant passer à l'étape serait sage
sébastien vraiment je suis assez curieux
ok c'est très joli et ça donne envie de
goûter
voilà je pense que si on peut écouter ça
vous intéresse pas pourquoi alors il ya
un lieu mystérieux et je pense qu'il
vous séduira beaucoup l on va vous
emmener vous accompagne vous faites
voilà et puis comme ça vous pourrez
goûter c'est un lieu et un petit peu
féerique
j'en dis pas plus andorre et ben alors
on a même fait avec nous voilà qu'elle
vient on va découvrir tout ça on y va
[Musique]